des gains. Les militants pros
choix veulent faire en sorte
qu'il y ait plus de cliniques
là-bas pour les femmes qui en
ont besoin et les militants pros
- My body!
- My choice!
- Les militants pro-choix
de St-Louis tentent d'organiser
la résistance, mais ils peinent
encore à croire que l'É
du Missouri a complètement
banni l'avortement.
"Je sais qu'ils crient
victoire, mais ils n'arriveront
pas à leurs fins", dit Bob Case.
"Quand vous allez voir toute
la misère que cela va provoquer,
quand les femmes doivent
traverser les frontières
de l'État et que ceux qui
les aideront iront,
là, ça va leur tomber dessus
comme une tonne de briques",
dit-il.
Pour avoir accès à
l'avortement, les femmes
de St-Louis devront traverser
le Mississippi et se rendre
dans l'État voisin, en Illinois,
où l'avortement est toujours
légal. Mais aucun transport
en commun n'est accessible
pour s'y rendre. La clinique
d'avortement recrute donc
des volontaires pour assurer
le transport.
(en anglais)
Sharon Lorinska n'a pas hésité
à se porter volontaire.
Elle ira volontiers chercher
les femmes du Missouri qui
souhaitent se faire avorter
en Illinois parce qu'elle se
souvient trop bien de
ce qu'était la vie avant
le jugement Roe contre Wade,
dit la retraitée.
Mais même en arrivant
à la clinique, la partie
n'est pas gagnée : des milit
anti-avortement montent la garde
à l'entrée.
"Planned Parenthood est la plus
importante clinique d'avortement
au sud de l'Illinois. Juste enfs
des conseillères qui offrent
des ressources et nos bureaux
sont à exactement 132 piedsde le
le directeur général
de Coalition for Life.
- Come on in! How are you,
Gretchen? Good morning.
- L'organisme compte 70 000
militants anti-avortement
au Missouri et en Illinois.
Et ici, rtement évité
est une victoire.
(en anglais)
"Nous o chaque cliente
une séance photo après
l'accouchement.
Toutes ces femmes ont considéré
l'avortement, mais elles ont
finalement choisi la vie",
dit Brian Westbrook.
Coalition for Life dit venir
en aide à 700 femmes
chaque année.
"Nous accrochons leurs photos
au mur. Ça nous rappelle
l'importance de ce que nous
faisons.
Et puis, les locaux sont
équipés d'une chapelle qui a une
vue directement sur la clinique
d'avortement.
"S'il fait froid dehors,
nos bénévoles peuvent venir
prier ici."
Avec la décision de la Cour
suprême, Coalition for Life
souhaite s'agrandir et étendre
ses activités jusqu'à Chicago. s
d'avortement là-bas,
alors on veut être présent
devant chacune d'elle."
Mais les militantx
de l'Illinois ont aussi
des projets d'expansion,
et une nouvelle clinique
d'avortement ouvrira bientôt
près de chez Sharon,
à Corbandale
"L'idée est d'aider les femmes
du sud des États-Unis où l'accès
en plus difficile. Ce sera
la clinique la plus proche
pour ces femmes au nord
du Kentucky. J'y sole
lorsqu'elle va ouvrir",
conclut Sharon.
Ici Valérie Gamache,
Radio-Canada, Belleville,
Illinoi